bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 6 juin tandis que le dispositif de
pompage de l'erika se mettent en place
des équipes de nettoyage s'active sur
les plages de loire-atlantique enquête à
la turballe et la vole
l'annnonce du quinquennat est en fait
les tenants et les opposants de la
réforme constitutionnelle se déclarer
long débat sur d'un possible amendement
umts qu'est ce que c'est c'est la
troisième génération de téléphonie
mobile qui permettra de recevoir des
services internet sur l'écran de son
téléphone et a défini les règles
d'attribution des fréquences
c'est notre affaire à tous ce titre du
livre publié par eva joly premier juge
d'instruction au tribunal de grande
instance de paris réflexion sur la
justice et la délinquance financière
mondiale eva joly notre invité dans
quelques minutes
bravo mary pierce la joueuse française
s'est qualifiée pour les demi finales
des internationaux de tennis de roland
garros après avoir battu monica seles et
puis un événement ce soir sur france 2
il y aura un document de rené jean
bouyer ils ont filmé la guerre en
couleurs des images tournées entre 1936
et 1944 totalement inédite
j'y reviendrai la fin de cette édition
donc depuis hier à quelque 70 kilomètres
au sud de penmarch dans le finistère des
plongeurs procède à l'installation du
dispositif de pompage du pétrolier erika
qui repose par 120 mètres de fond ce
matin ils ont posé une première vannes
sur les passes tandis qu'une deuxième
équipe colmater une légère fuite repérée
à l'arrière quatre navires sont sur la
zone et complète donc l'ensemble du
dispositif total fina estime à 12 mille
tonnes le volume de fioul resté
prisonnier dans les cales
on fera le calcul exact après le pompage
s'il réussit en attendant c'est bel et
bien sur les côtes de la loire
atlantique que l'on constate jour après
jour des effets désastreux de la marée
noire déclenchée le 12 décembre 99 on
avait dit qu'il faudrait quelques mois
pour nettoyer les rochers les sables
s'est largement faut pour certaines
parties de la côte sauvage non loin du
croisic
c'est un peu plus exact vers la baule
enquête close sans terre et christian
galley
la course contre la montre continue la
saison touristique approche
il faut vite essayer d'effacer des
dernières traces de la marée noire
nous sommes à la turballe un des plus
jolis port de loire atlantique depuis ce
matin plus de 600 militaires et pompiers
avec des tenues de protection ont
entrepris une opération de nettoyage
sans précédent à côté du port sur le
sable on trouvait encore ces derniers
jours quelques petites plaques de
pétrole ici cet été seulement une partie
de la plage sera ouverte au public dans
chaque commune la décision d'ouverture
ou de fermeture appartient aux maires
sur nos côtes on a effectivement besoin
d'avoir des zones de plage
maintenant je fais une entière confiance
la responsabilité des élus et je pense
que depuis le début personne n'a menti
donc je vois pas de quel serait
l'intérêt d'un maire de laisser une
plage ouverte et de dire au public
qu'elle est propre
parce que à terme ce serait condamner
ces stations quelques kilomètres plus au
sud
nous découvrons la côte sauvage dans
chaque creek les rochers le sol sont
encore largement imprégnée de pétrole
devant le restaurant côté plaint une
nouvelle équipe de pompiers vient
d'arriver à l'intérieur de la crêperie
aucun client et la patronne qui fait les
cent pas ça va un peu mieux maintenant
mais je dois dire que pendant pendant
cinq mois je vais j'allais très très mal
j'ai fait une dépression oui
bon il faut tenir de façon je ne vais
pas je ne peux pas me permettre de
sacrifier 20 ans de travail j'ai des
emprunts j'ai une maison avec des
emprunts j'ai acheté les murs j'ai
acheté le commerce
actuellement j'ai mis ma maison en vente
parce que je ne sais pas ce qu'il va
être pour cet hiver
13h35 toujours personne chiffre
d'affaires au mois de mai - 50 %
quelques centaines de mètres plus loin
toujours sur la côte sauvage
le restaurant d'antonio même situation
même colère
en fait ils ont pas discerner que
c'était vraiment la cata et en fait
c'est pour ça qu'on se retrouve encore
aujourd'hui avec cette merde là c'est
parce que au début personne n'y a cru
mais malheureusement ça a fait c'est là
et ça va être là encore pendant un
moment
dernière étape de notre voyage
la boule ici la plage est ouverte dans
sa totalité et le week-end dernier l'
accueillait plusieurs milliers de
vacanciers loin du pétrole loin de
l'erika chacun voulait voir dans ces
images une lueur d'espoir mais à ce
constat il faut ajouter une découverte
faite par le collectif anti marée noire
de saint nazaire très actif depuis le
naufrage de l'erika ce collectif aurait
retrouvé
vous le voyez du pétrole dans un puits
d'eau douce situé sur la plage de
pornichet alors va donc pour le
quinquennat on l'annonçait le président
chirac l'a dit hier sur sur cette
antenne première date sur le calendrier
qui pourrait mener un possible
référendum en septembre débat à
l'assemblée sans doute le 20 juin au
sénat le 22 juin mais outre les
oppositions marqué au quinquennat promis
le débat s'est notamment porté
aujourd'hui sur la possibilité ou non
d'amande reportage suit le boisserie
ne demandez pas lionel jospin comment il
a trouvé jacques chirac hier soir il ne
répondra pas son seul objectif
aujourd'hui convaincre ses alliés comme
ce matin les députés communistes de
voter sans crainte ni réticence la
réforme du quinquennat et rien de plus
un discours repris en choeur à
l'assemblée nationale par les
socialistes comme par les alliés en chef
de l'état les députés socialistes ont
pas l'intention de déposer d'amendement
au projet de loi du gouvernement qui
doit être adopté demain donc ses 55 ans
nous sommes ni dans la 6e ni la 7è nous
sommes date vème république
là c'était pas public qui se modernise
qui s'adapte la constitution est une
règle ne suis pas une règle intangible
un point de vue que tout le monde ne
partage pas à droite et notamment dans
le camp de jean louis debré un autre de
plus en plus dans la 6ème république car
je crois que la dissolution ratée sans
conséquence présidentiel a déjà été un
premier coup de canif dans la cinquième
à nouveau très bon j'ai bien compris je
l'approuverai pas cet extrait
d'un côté avec amsterdam en diminue les
pouvoirs du parlement puis maintenant
avec cette réforme on diminue les
pouvoirs du président
pourquoi pas deux ans d'ailleurs chirac
deux ans pour ne rien faire ça c'est
encore mieux le franchement dans la
majorité plurielle les critiques se font
moins radicale surtout on voudrait aller
plus loin quitte à revoir le dogme de la
vème république
si on veut passer à la cera la 6ème
république pourquoi pas mais pendant
discute et qu'on en discute autrement
qu'avec des en jouant au jeu du chat et
la souris entre le premier ministre le
président de la république
le débat sur le quinquennat le 14 juin
prochain promet donc d'être animé la
vème république sera soumise à un nouvel
examen de passage sans prendre forcément
beaucoup de risques alors toutes les
questions génération de au début de
quelque chose si c'est un quinquennat
c'est quoi un quinquennat qui fait des
petits c'est l'aboutissement de
commencement c'est ça qu'on veut
absolument vous l'avez dit le
quinquennat aboutissement ou
commencement c'est toute la question
jacques chirac a plaidé hier pour une
réforme a minima cinq ans au lieu de
sept mais sans limitation du nombre des
mandats sans changement de calendrier
des élections et puis surtout sans
aucune autre modification des
institutions
fermez le banc une proposition donc
simple et claire approuvé ce matin par
lionel jospin mais une prestation
présidentielle qui a paru manquer
d'arguments de conviction à un nombre de
parlementaires de la majorité de
l'opposition craintes chez les uns que
charles pasqua en soit le principal
bénéficiaire en enfourchant le cheval du
non au référendum
un satisfaction de tous ceux ou centre
ou à gauche qui souhaitait ajouter au
quinquennat
d'autres mesures comme le non cumul des
mandats une dose de proportionnelle ou
bien la revalorisation du parlement
et puis frustration enfin des partisans
d'une évolution vers un régime
présidentiel avec disparition du poste
de premier ministre et du droit de
dissolution une sorte de sixième
république dont justement jacques chirac
ne veut à aucun prix
non tout cela promet un été plutôt chaud
que ce plan politique oui oui avec à
l'assemblée force débat et amendements
mais la discipline de vote au sein des
groupes ps et repères et des ailes
devraient sur une majorité au
quinquennat sec
l'incertitude est plus grande au sénat
où les élus sont plus indépendants et
ils craignent pour certains une remise
en cause de la durée du mandat
sénatorial
il restera enfin l'épreuve
du référendum avec les répercussions
possibles de ces polémiques sur la
mobilisation et le vote des français
voulaient compris le quinquennat bien
que favori n'est pas encore au bout de
ses peines
merci bien le gouvernement a choisi une
procédure de sélection sur dossier non
pas des enchères publiques comme en
angleterre ou encore en allemagne pour
attribuer des licences de téléphonie
mobile multimédia licences qui sont
mises en service à partir de janvier
2002 cette attribution devrait rapporter
130 milliards de francs explications à
camano et laurence iront l'internet dans
un portable c'est l'activité principale
de la pop une entreprise créée il ya
tout juste trois mois
pour elle le développement de l'ue mts
le nouveau réseau de téléphonie mobile
est essentielle plus d'informations sur
un écran de portable c'est plus de
services à attendre donc plus d'argent a
récolté pour nous lui était ça veut dire
qu'il faut x nice par 20 par trois nos
effectifs ne développeurs le
développement pour faire plus de
services mieux plus rapide plus
accessible cette démultiplication des
services est une véritable manne pour
les opérateurs
on sait ce soir qui seront 4 et qu'ils
seront sélectionnés sur dossier chacun
devra payer 32 milliard et demi de
francs à l'état au total
celui-ci empochera une somme de 136
milliards de francs pour le ministre des
finances c'est bel et bien le juste prix
si le prix est fixé trop bas on dilapide
le patrimoine public
s'il est trop on risque de pénaliser les
consommateurs les petites villes ou les
petites entreprises et les opérateurs
industriels
le gouvernement a donc choisi d'écarter
le principe d'une vente aux enchères qui
aurait pu rapporter bien plus malgré
cela le ticket d'entrée semble déjà trop
cher pour les futurs candidats
nous avons l'impression d'être des
otages dans cette procédure
et quel que soit le mot qui sera
utilisée lorsque l'on vous oblige pour
continuer à exercer votre activité à
repayer
il s'agit d'un impôt c 130 milliards
récoltés grâce à cette technologie
d'avenir devrait servir à résoudre un
problème avec
pire ils seront affectés pour
l'essentiel au fonds de réserve pour les
retraites
alors maintenant que l'on sait comment
ces licences seront attribuées il faut
sans doute revenir aux sources et
définir plus précisément ce que sera
cette troisième génération de téléphonie
mobile
ses implications dans notre vie
quotidienne commentaires patrice pollet
avec jean-paul miotto la fréquences umts
c'est l'arrivée des images sur le
téléphone mobile un débit numérique 40
fois plus puissant pour aujourd'hui sur
internet permettra de voir ceci le monde
sur quelques centimètres quatre autres
exemples on appelle depuis un portable
et chacun de son côté peut voir l'autre
lui mts offre des possibilités à couper
le souffle
vous pourrez connecter en fait cet
appareil est cet appareil sans fil
naturellement l'un avec l'autre
vous pourrez prendre une photo avec
votre caméra numérique et vous pourrez
l'envoyer à la personne de votre choix à
l'autre bout du monde
on pourrait regarder la télévision pas
sur ce type d'appareil sur un appareil
qui aurait une forme légèrement
différente qui aurait probablement un
écran légèrement plus grand avec de la
couleur mais on pourrait parfaitement
regardé de la télévision
les premiers téléphones mobiles
fonctionnant sur la fréquence umts
arriveront sur le marché en 2002 a
fantastic espace va s'ouvrir plein
d'inventer une première hypothèse encore
provisoires pour le déraillement de
l'eurostar hier après-midi près d'arras
dans le pas-de-calais une pièce du
système de transmission du bogie arrière
de la motrice de tête aurait été arraché
la sncf parle de sortie de raï partiel
je rappelle que 13 personnes ont été
blessées légèrement
le président américain bill clinton a
quitté tard hier soir l'ukraine pas
avoir entendu des autorités de kiev lé
annonce de la fermeture définitive le 15
décembre 2000 de la centrale de
tchernobyl d'une promesse faite dead 2
78 millions $ près de 550 millions de
francs a donc été fait par les
américains pour la construction d'un
nouveau sarcophage pour le réacteur de
cette centrale qui avait explosé en 1986
commentaires mulvenon
ils sont encore plus de 3000 à
travailler dans la centrale de
tchernobyl plus d'ailleurs pour réparer
les pannes à répétition et gérer le
vieillissement accéléré du réacteur
numéro 3 le dernier a fonctionné du
moins à 30% de son régime
mais hier l'ukraine a décidé de fermer
définitivement la centrale d'ici six
mois une décision que les ingénieurs
accepte sous conditions il y a plusieurs
scénarios pour fermer la centrale sans
risque mais il va falloir surtout
imaginer le mieux possible
comment gérer le combustible radioactif
est aussi le personnel qui travaille ici
tchernobyl synonyme de catastrophe avril
86 l'explosion du réacteur numéro 4
l'âge dans l'atmosphère l'équivalent de
500 bombes d'hiroshima 1991 un incendie
oblige l'arrêt du réacteur numéro 2 1995
le réacteur numéro 1 cette fois qui est
stoppé à cause de fissures
si la communauté internationale versent
les 14 milliards de francs promis il ya
cinq ans pour reconstruire de nouvelles
centrales l'ukraine se débarrassera
enfin de tchernobyl il faudra ensuite
régler une question majeure celle du
sarcophage de confinement en béton
construit à l'acte après l'accident de
86 on s'aperçoit qu'il vieillit beaucoup
plus vite beaucoup plus mal que ce qui
était prévu il ya un risque sérieux
l'effondrement partiel du sarcophage
pour reconstruire cette structure les
etats-unis ont annoncé qu'elles
verseront 550 millions de francs 10 % ce
qui est nécessaire mais pour nettoyer
complètement le site il faudra 50 ans et
70 milliards de francs une somme loin
d'être réunies la secrétaire d'état des
états-unis madeleine albright a
rencontré à ramallah le président arafat
puis à jérusalem
moubarak un sommet arafat barak clinton
serait prévue la semaine prochaine à
washington mais il y encore des
réticences
toujours pour tenter d'accélérer le
processus de paix un processus souvent
contesté à gaza et dans les territoires
dépendant de l'autorité palestinienne de
plus les médias palestiniens multiplient
souvent les critiques à l'égard de la
gestion de l'équipe de yasser arafat
conséquences des fermetures arbitraire
de stations de radio télévision et des
arrestations de journalistes en quête de
nos correspondants permanents charles
enderlin ossiam c'était à ramallah au
cours des obsèques d'un militant du
front populaire tués lors d'un
accrochage avec l'armée il serait mort
ahmed boukous belle pourtant haut
fonctionnaire scandaient nous voulons
nos droits pas de négociations secrètes
plus tard la police palestinienne
empêcher des manifestants de s'approcher
une implantation juive des images
embarrassantes pour l'autorité
palestinienne qui en a empêché la
diffusion sur les chaînes locales watan
la télévision privée de ramallah a été
fermée le soir même je risque d'être
arrêtée à tout moment avec les autres
journalistes palestiniens nous vivons
dans la crainte
notre station peut être ferme et
n'importe quand arbitrairement
watan a pu recommencer à diffuser après
trois jours c'était sa cinquième
fermeture mais elle m'a aide la station
de télévision privée de bethléem est
encore fermé sur ordre de la police
motif son directeur a publié un
communiqué de soutien à watan personne
ne vous sent sûr mais lorsqu'une erreur
est commise
on vous ferme la station on ne vous dit
pas pourquoi il n'y a jamais rien
d'écrit il a passé 48 heures en
détention à manama a marre le patron
d'el nasr une autre station privée est
interdit de diffusion
un député palestinien avait critiqué
yasser arafat au cours d'un débat
je ne sais pas quel crime j'ai commis je
ne peux pas rester les bras croisés
quand il ferme la station je n'ai rien
fait de mal et si je dois finir en
prison elle va tant pis quelques
dizaines de journalistes palestiniens
ont manifesté jeudi dernier à ramallah
pour la liberté de la presse
leur liberté un détail aucun responsable
de l'autorité palestinienne à accepter
d'être interviewés pour ce reportage
au liban le tribunal militaire juge
depuis hier 158 ancien membre de l'armée
du liban sud la milice pro israélienne
déjà des peines de six mois à cinq ans
de prison ont été infligées plusieurs
dizaines de soldats de la ls que l'on
voit ici
selon gouvernement libanais 1500 - de
l'eau l'air de la laisse ce serait pour
l'instant rendu encore un tremblement de
terre en turquie un séisme de magnitude
5,9 sur l'échelle de richter a été
constatée dans la province de chiang
kerry c'est dans le nord du pays on
compte trois morts et 80 blessés
à paris les juges chargés de l'enquêté
sur la mutuelle des étudiants de france
unef ont mis en examen le député
socialiste jean-marie le guen
les magistrats lui ont notifié les
charges de recel de détournement de
fonds publics pour se battre contre la
criminalité organisée qui on soupçonne
dans le monde financier international il
y a urgence de créer une architecture
politico judiciaire c'est l'un des
appels aux états que lens eva joly dans
son livre notre affaire à tous publiés
aux éditions des arènes la revendre
recevoir eva joly premier juge
d'instruction au tribunal de grande
instance de paris
elle fait on note qu elle fait également
dans son livre les loges du magistrat
suisse bernard bertossa et fait partie
comme elle de ces magistrats lancer dans
une vérité
le guerre contre les fraudes financières
ou encore le blanchiment d'argent
quelquefois des interrogations critiques
venues des élus politiques commentaires
michel film et philippe jasmin voilà
déjà sept ans qu'elle instruite au
palais de justice de paris
les dossiers financiers eva joly et le
magistrat qui a mise en examen bernard
tapie ancien ministre
loïk le floch prigent ex pdg d'elf
roland dumas ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel
les dossiers lourds parmi les plus
difficiles à instruire
de l'autre côté des alpes le procureur
de genève bernard bertossa mène avec eva
joly le même combat contre la
délinquance des puissants ça n'a rien
d'une croisade je rappelle quand même
que les cette corruption c'est pas nous
les juges qui avons décidé qu'ils
étaient décret mais c'est bien le
législateur qu'il a fait nous appliquons
la loi qui est fait par le parlement et
cette loi est une et indivisible
il n'est pas équitable de ne l'appliqué
cas des causes facile des délinquants de
peu d'importance et sous prétexte de
difficultés de renoncer à l'appliquer à
ceux qui commettent des crimes beaucoup
plus grave mais le message a parfois du
mal à passer
nous sommes à l'assemblée nationale il y
à un mois eva joly est l'invité vedette
de la commission d' enquête sur le
blanchiment
sa cible ce jour là la fraude fiscale la
france n'est pas un pays qui aime la
transparence
nous avons une très grande indulgence
pour la fraude fiscale c'est un sport
national dans l'assistance les députés
écoute mais tous n'apprécient pas ce
n'est pas elle de porter ce genre de
jugement d'ordre général il faut qu'elle
s'attache elle le fait le fait très bien
d'ailleurs à des affaires en tant que
tel à des investigations
il faut lui faciliter la tâche mais elle
n'a pas besoin d'en rajouter et n'a pas
besoin de donner des leçons de morale à
quiconque
ce jour là en quittant l'assemblée
nationale la juge eva joly ne semblait
pas avoir entendu le message du député
eva joly bonsoir vous avez entendu comme
ce message est ce que vous ne donnez pas
effectivement quelques fois vous et
d'autres magistrats des leçons morales
aux élus politiques
je ne pense pas qu'il s'agisse de morale
je pense qu'elle sache et de lutte
contre une forme de criminalité qui est
très grave et je pense qu'il ya une
discordance extrêmement importante et
grave entre les intentions déclarées et
la réalité du tyran et c'est je crois ce
que bertossa et moi même et beaucoup
d'autres matches et cela ira vite
dénoncé vous savez ce que vous reprochez
vous le relevez dans votre genre dans
votre livre vous dites vous récusez vous
dites on a l'impression que je suis en
croisade
c'est pas vrai non je pense que ces
témoignages l effet d quelqu'un que par
un achat historique se trouvait placé
dans cette position d'avoir observé à la
fois l'archaïsme de l'institution sont
postés vieillot son côté démunis et les
portes et incroyablement moderne et dans
le vent la délinquance économique est de
constater notre impuissance face à cela
et vous dites notamment plus de la
moitié de nos très grandes entreprises
françaises sont donc directement est
quotidiennement confronté la délinquance
financière
vous gérez pas un peu pour je pense que
comme beaucoup de confrères européens
nous avons pensé pendant très longtemps
qu'il s'agissait d'un épiphénomène de
quelques vrais des gras le galeuses
quelqu'un quelques écarts de conduite et
nous savons je crois est terminée à
faire le constat que c'était un problème
beaucoup plus répandu que cela est ce
que nous constatons également peu fait
que pour combattre fait canal était si
grave
nous avons peu d'enquêteurs et que la
réforme de la police de 95 nous a privé
notre nom bras pour faire les cinq
caisses c'est parce qu'on avait couvert
un peu sur l'auteur cette délinquance ou
commencent à en prendre conscience
vous tapez beaucoup sur la cob
commission des opérations de bourse vous
dites que transmet qu'une petite dizaine
de cas litigieux
alors que il ya en une seule journée on
peut blanchir 200 millions de francs en
fait vous dites qu'ils font pas grand
chose que je dis que nous sommes pas
outillés pour appréhender cette
délinquance est lié mais vous avez
toujours vous dites qu'on a pas une
vraie volonté d'y aller oui je pense
qu'on peut
on peut appréhender la volonté politique
de lutter contre cette délinquance
non pas dans les déclarations
d'intention non pas d'aller moore mais
dans les actions
et quand on me sur les actions moi je
constate que nous avons perdu 4000
policiers en 4ème lille au pg quatre
amis donc policiers capable de faire s
inquiète
en peu d'années que la brigade
financière et démunis ont manqué dix
enquêteurs que les charges nouvelles
mobilisations syndicales que vous faites
non c'est pas syndical c'est pour les
citoyens c'est pour cependant attention
quand vous dis que plus de 95% des
délits financiers ne sont pas récents
punis là aussi vous n'exagérez pas un
peu d'entre nous dire il ya nice berg
énorme nous fait je vous dis qu'il ya un
an espère qu'elle que nous connaissons
qu'une infime partie et que tout le
bruit fait autour de cette affaire ne
doit pas faire oublier cela ce que nous
connaissons qui réclament les parts que
vous vous heurtez vous monsieur beer
tous ceux d'autres à une délinquance
financière mondiale or les états ont
chacun leurs lois leurs justice donc
c'est ça la complication sinon oui nous
nous sommes enfermés dans nos frontières
les juges ne peuvent pas aller chercher
les renseignements bas les pays voisins
et au sein même de l'europe
nous tolérons des paradis fiscaux venu
comme nous tolérons des endroits ont la
peau luxembourg johnston les kingston
par exemple est un exemple très très
important et qui vient d'être décrit par
un rapport parlementaire
il y a là un blanchiment important et la
liechtenstein ne cois perd pas avec les
juges européens
alors vous récusé l'idée d'être
puissantes du commun vous mettez quand
même des gens en prison c'est quand même
la puissance incroyable
je crois qu'il faut être conscient que
l'action publique qui le fait de lutter
contre la délinquance est une tâche
noble aps la société et qu'elle est
confiée au juge et qu'elle juge passent
leur temps à arbitrer entre les intérêts
particuliers les intérêts individuels la
liberté individuelle et la nécessité de
l'action publique
et lorsqu'il le juge met en détention
provisoire lorsqu'il prononce une peine
c'est parce que il s'estime que c'est
dans l'intérêt de l'action publique
il fonce à la plupart du temps un très
bon escient et je voudrais dire à propos
de ça qu'est la france a une population
pénitentiaire faible nous avons à peu
près 55 les techniques d régulièrement
dénoncés pour avoir de détentions
provisoires trop longues pour des délais
de jugement trop long alors là il a un
des actions spectaculaires ne plus
savoir s'il y avait une réelle volonté
de s'attaquer au problème
par exemple les personnes qui sont en
attente d'être traduit devant la cour
d'assisses attend un an
souvent c'est le délai minimum
actuellement avant d'être envoyées il se
passe rien
cette année là on peut le raccourcir ce
film était magistrat en face et le
nombre de personnes en détention
provisoire par le juge financier est
dérisoire
j'ai une dernière question à vous poser
parce que vous semblez quelqu'un de très
fort très costaud avec de très fortes
convictions mais est ce que une fois
vous êtes trompés est ce que vous
regrettez d'avoir pris une décision tant
que juge une fois savez nous sommes
passés cinq sauvage eva joly ne sommes
pas aussi sale que vous le croyez nous
travailler en équipe
donc nous parlions beaucoup discutons
beaucoup entre nous tu as des questions
à prendre nous travaillons avec les
policiers avec le parquet avec les
experts donc les décisions sont pesées
mais vous êtes trompé quand même une
fois vous pensez vous avez commis une
erreur je pense qui parfois chez mal
estimé l'importance de chaque
protagoniste dossier mais je ne pense
pas m'être beaucoup trompé
merci madame d'être venu nous fait votre
ligne notre affaire à tous aux éditions
les arènes
merci les avocats de sid ahmed rezala
vont présenter à un ultime recours
contre l'accord constitutionnel du
portugal pour tenter d'empêcher la mise
en application de la décision de la cour
de cassation de lisbonne d'extrader le
meurtrier présumé de trois femmes vers
la france l'ouverture aujourd'hui à
paris du congrès eurocancer les
spécialistes y ont déploré les
insuffisances du dépistage du cancer en
france et on a aussi observé avec
intérêt les progrès de l'imagerie
médicale la capacité d'utiliser le
virtuel pour des opération très délicate
explications et florent muller et rémy
poissonnier
bienvenue dans la trachée artère d'un
patient l'objectif est une frappe
chirurgicale
attention ceci n'est pas un simple
simulateur car la tumeur cancéreuse est
bien réelle pascal pelle ne donne pas le
droit à l'erreur mais ici en quelques
clics le chirurgien examine le malade
sous toutes ses coutures avant
l'intervention pour faire naître ses
effets très spéciaux il suffit d'un
banal examen au scanner pour l'instant
pas de quoi vous couper le souffle
l'appareil a pris une centaine de
clichés du patient ces radios
traditionnelles permettent d'établir un
premier diagnostic à traiter par la rage
active totale circulaire de rattrapage à
l'aide de calcul tout aussi obscur
l'ordinateur va additionner ses clichés
pour offrir une vue en trois dimensions
du patient de ces tissus et le sa
structure osseuse en voyageant
virtuellement à l'intérieur du malade le
chirurgien peut repérer les lieux avant
l'intervention délicate
le chirurgien d'après opérer un patient
donné son patient et non pas un modèle
prédéfini moyens c'est réellement le
patient qu'il va opérer qu'il voit avant
l'intervention
ici par exemple
river jusqu'au nouveau de ce qui
représente ici une tumeur qui s'est
développée dans la bouche et qui arrive
au contact de l'os pour l'heure ces
logiciels sont encore au banc d'essai à
l'institut gustave roussy leur prix
n'est pas trop élevé mais avant de
songer à un tel investissement les
hôpitaux français devront combler un
retard ils sont en europe parmi les
moins équipés en scanner et en irm des
appareils pourtant essentiel à la
détection d'une tumeur cancéreuse du
sport avec une bien belle journée aux
internationaux de tennis de roland
garros pour les spectateurs et
téléspectateurs de france télévisions
ils ont vu de beaux matchs notamment
kuerten face à kafelnikov avec la
victoire à l'arraché du premier mais
aussi et surtout la qualification de
mary pierce face à monica seles mary
pierce jouera en demi-finale contre
martina hingis
retour sur cette belle victoire avec
christelle bertrand et jean gicquel
c'est un moment intime au milieu de la
reine mary pierce a changé désormais le
calme l'envahît toujours après la
tempête
son jeu a mûri sa volonté a grandi et
face à monica seles
elle sait qu'il faut prendre tous les
points au sérieux dans le premier jeu la
française défend comme jamais jusqu'à
réussir des coups inédits
mais monica seles ne se laisse pas
impressionner l'américaine comme à son
habitude parvient à trouver des angles
dans les angles et remporte le premier
set 6 4
mais à ce moment là la française
retrouve une bonne première balle de
service prendre seles de vitesse devient
beaucoup plus facile
pearce gagne la deuxième manche 6-3 et
puis elle prend le large au début de la
dernière manche jusqu'à avoir quand je
davance mais céleste ne s'avoue jamais
vaincu l'américaine rattrape son retard
tous les points sont décisifs
la nouvelle force de pierce c'est sa
ténacité désormais plus sereine la
française a pu tenir tête à céleste mary
pierce s'impose en trois sets et se fait
adopter par le public français si
difficile acharnée mary pierce est
maintenant sûr qu'en demi finale face à
martina hingis
elle pourra compter sur lui
françois-marie tierces merci d'être
resté à roland garos juste avec quelques
petites questions
alors on part de votre ténacité oreilles
mais comment vous arrivez à faire un
coup pareil c'est raquette entre les
gens vous rattraper la balle comment il
fait ça c'est mon préféré
je dois pas le faire mais c'est mon coup
préféré et puis pendant ce point là j'ai
essayé d'attraper la balle de quoi et
puis je suis arrivé trop vite sur la
balle et puis bon c'est la seule chose à
faire
alors ça veut dire que vous amusez quand
même en faisant ça puisque vous devez
pas le faire plaisir et une impression
vous aviez un vrai grand plaisir cet
après midi face à monica seles d'abord
parce que vous étiez soutenu d'abord
parce qu'ils étaient très concentrés
vous avez retrouvé ou trouver un vrai
grand plaisir à jouer maintenant
oui j'ai toujours un plaisir de jouer au
tennis mais c'est vrai que bon ces
derniers temps je me sens très détendue
et puis très calme sur le terrain et
puis j'essaie de réfléchir et puis de
penser ce qu'il faut faire
des jouets dangereux à chaque fois
lorsque vous apprêtez engagé il ya une
forme de réflexion de concentration très
particulière des amis au point non pas
vraiment je sais d'écouter un plat
mythique avant les matchs de penser aux
stratégies ce que j'ai envie de faire et
un petite prière et puis c'est bon mais
alors là vous avez une pression énorme
vous êtes la seule française
on va tous vous soutenir c'est une
pression que vous avez géré et comment
un bon je sais pas trop penser à ça
parce que sinon la plata servat montés
et puis bon c'est vrai que ça peut me
rendre un peu crispé bon si je suis
triste et je pas mon jeu je ne veux pas
agressive en attaquant en avançant donc
bon c'est vrai qu'un peu de pression
aujourd'hui j'ai senti un petit peu mais
bon après dans le deuxième set je me
sentais bien détendu et puis ça s'est
bien passé
alors la particularité c'est que vous
allez jouer contre martina hingis qui
est votre partenaire de double puis
c'est vrai on va jouer le duc de maïs en
épis bachar el-assad
j'ai dit voilà il on vous souhaite très
très bonne chance
merci beaucoup merci la fin d'une très
belle carrière pour jean luc crétier le
skieur alpin décidé de mettre un terme à
ses exploits il fut couronné en février
98 de champion olympique
trente ans après jean claude killy on
s'en souvient c'était un haga nos il y a
il a 34 ans est un peu tôt il avait
conservé mais de toute façon la
fédération internationale de ski ne lui
donnait pas une invitation pour la
prochaine saison de coupe du monde du
cinéma avec les sorties mercredi
prochain sur les écrans du film d'un
rêve à l'hôte d'alain berliner
celui ci avait déjà réalisé ma vie en
rose avec michèle laroque
cette fois il utilise le talent de débit
moore la berline est rentrer ainsi à
petits pas dans l'univers du cinéma
américain avec une histoire
tout compte fait assez française
présentation marie-jo jouant et andres
izarra
c'est l'histoire de marie qui vit dans
un village provençal avec ses deux
filles est surtout une guitare chaque
mois elle s'endort il devient marty
agent littéraire à new york d'un rêve à
l'autre la jeune femme traverse deux
univers reste à savoir lequel est réel
passer d'un rêve à l'autre c'est un peu
ce qui vient d'arriver alain berliner un
premier long métrage en 97 ma vie en
rose qui fait un tabac outre atlantique
un an plus tard il reçoit le scénario de
ron basques auteurs de rain man
il leur travail et voilà ce jeune
cinéaste belge propulsé à new york
dirigeants demi moore dans une
production américaine
un rêve d'autant plus qu'il a pu choisir
l'actrice des quelque chose qui s'est
passé et qui son approche du rôle était
séduisante et en tous les cas très
surprenante mais c'est vrai que j'avais
un peu une autre image d'elle au moment
de la rencontrer
il va aussi un petit peu de discussion
en discussion le fil en aiguille l'idée
dame de l'apprendre elle pour jouer un
rôle dans lequel on l'attend pas
réellement puisqu'il a plutôt les plutôt
typé 13 studios hollywoodiens
quelque chose de très enfants et l'amour
avec lui et l'année dernière sait même
pas s'ils existent
pardon je vous ai fait l'amour la nuit
dernière en france
oui un très beau rôle de femme au bord
de la schizophrénie l'occasion pour demi
moore de retrouver une jolie place à
l'écran grâce au regard neuf d'un
cinéaste européen qui a su garder son
identité
pour compliquer le tout le temps à
partir du moment quand même il fallait
ça réalisateur pour faire un film il ya
quand même un côté confiance
ils n'ont pas non plus choisi pour rien
donc ou pas faut pas penser que j'avais
quelqu'un dans mon dos tout le temps
pour me poser des questions remettre en
question ont chois gare actuellement
loin de là d'un rêve à loutre a été
tourné entre le luberon et new york
alain berliner ne connaissait ni là ni
l'eau peut-être ce qui lui a permis de
garder les pieds sur terre
face à une aventure qui en auraient
effrayé plus d'un le film vient de
sortir aux états unis
succès ou pas en france pour berline r
ce qu'ils font et de pouvoir continuer à
raconter des histoires qui touche les
gens et dans toutes les langues
et puis ce soir sur france 2 vous
pourrez assister à la diffusion d'un
document inédit tout à fait exceptionnel
il est intitulé ils ont filmé la guerre
en couleurs après trois ans de recherche
rené jean bouyer propose un document de
films au pluriel en couleurs tourné
entre 1936 et 1944 depuis la guerre
d'espagne jusqu'à hiroshima notamment
avant même cette diffusion vers 20h50
quelques explications
elle ferait des régions et jean luc
boussard adolf hitler en noir et blanc
sans doute avez vous l'impression
d'avoir vu cent fois ces images mais
qu'en pensez vous comme ceci
ces scènes n'ont pas été colorisées
elles ont été tournées il ya plus de 50
ans directement en couleurs à l'aide de
caméras d'amateurs pendant un demi
siècle
ces films sont restées inexploitées
parfois dans les caves ou les greniers
de leurs propriétaires pour la plupart
allemands soviétique ou américains
certains de ces documents ont été
tournées par les cinéastes officiel mais
d'autres sont le fait de simples hommes
du rang le résultat un réalisme étonnant
comme ici lors du débarquement de
normandie en 1944
des images que la couleur en plus proche
de nous
la valeur ajoutée de la couleur c'est
que ça a aboli le temps c'est que
brusquement on sort du livre d'histoire
et que quand on voit ces images on a
l'impression de voir le journal télévisé
d'hier soir ils sont là ils sont à côté
de nous et c'est formidablement
émouvante la légèreté des caméra 16 mm
permettent aux soldats de saisir la
réalité de la guerre par exemple ces
réfugiés français filmés par un soldat
de la wehrmacht en mai 1940
des images qui n'était encore jamais
sorti des tiroirs
en première ligne ces soldats cameramen
tournent parfois en cachette de la
propagande officielle
il montre sans fard une europe à genoux
la détresse des populations envahi
l'horreur du ghetto de varsovie
des années 30 à 1945 plusieurs milliers
de bobines ont été retrouvés pour que
celles et ceux qui ont vécu le plus
terrible conflit mondial retrouve enfin
un visage
voilà c'est ce soir sur france 2 arrive
en la fin de cette édition je rappelle
deux actualités nous avons développé le
gouvernement attribuera les fréquences
de téléphonie mobile nouvelle génération
sur dossier par soumission cette
nouvelle téléphonie mobile nous
permettra notamment d'avoir internet
divers services sur les portables
et puis la belle victoire de marie
pierre sur monica seles ou international
roland garros quand et pierre jouera en
demi-finale face à martina hingis la
météo dans quelques secondes avec
isabelle martinet demain 13h retrouvez
carole gaessler rachida avec une large
partie de leur édition consacrée à les
ricains à demain 20h bonsoir merci
autre
oh